[Musik]
unterwegs auf der Straße als einfacher
Helfer man weiß nie wann und wo die
nächste Granate trifft
[Musik]
bleib stehen deine Medikamente sind hier
auf der Seite
was tun wenn das eigene Land angegriffen
wird in der Ukraine helfen
hunderttausende freiwillig im Krieg
gegen Russland
ich dachte verdammt ich kann doch nicht
einfach zu Hause rumsitzen und nichts
tun
viele machen nun Jobs die sie noch nie
gemacht haben
man kann sagen wir holen Fahrzeuge von
den Toten zurück
von der barmanagerin zur
versorgungshelferin
auf der anderen Seite waren Russen es
gab einen Treffer 200 Meter neben uns
dies sind die Geschichten von Menschen
die ihr Leben riskieren um anderen zu
helfen und ein Land in Kriegszustand am
Laufen halten
[Musik]
Mario Pohl im März 2022 drei Wochen nach
Kriegsbeginn in einem ehemaligen
Nachtclub verstecken sich 200 Menschen
vor den Bomben der russischen Angreifer
Mysterio wir sind den Menschen und den
Kindern so nahe gekommen ich wurde
gebeten Pate zu werden
[Musik]
vor einer unmöglichen Entscheidung
wen soll er in seinem kleinen
Lieferwagen mitnehmen und wen wird er in
Kriegsgebiet zurücklassen
[Musik]
man kann sie doch nicht im Stich lassen
das ist als würde man seine Familie
aufgeben
[Musik]
die Vorbereitungen für die Flucht laufen
als plötzlich ein russisches
kriegsflugzeug auftaucht
verdammt das Flugzeug [__]
bist du okay
einen Moment scheint es als sein
michaelos Rettungsplan gescheitert
seit Kriegsbeginn wächst in der Ukraine
die Zahl der Freiwilligen für die
zivilen Helfer wie für alle Ukraine ist
seit dem Angriff nichts mehr wie es war
vor dem Krieg hatte ich ein normales
Leben ich hatte ein Geschäft meinen
eigenen Nachtclub in Mario
mein Leben war interessant und ich
wollte unbedingt in meiner Heimatstadt
erfolgreich sein
in der Ukraine gibt es eine Zeitrechnung
vor
und nach dem russischen Angriff
am 24 Februar 2022 dringen russische
Truppen in die Ukraine
ist eines der ersten Ziele
[Musik]
noch am selben Tag bringt mich Heiler
seine Familie in die Westukraine in
Sicherheit seine Angestellten sind noch
in Mario Polen
[Musik]
als ich die Stadt verließ versprach ich
dass ich zurückkommen würde dass alles
gut wird
doch inzwischen haben russische Soldaten
Mario Poll eingekesselt
michailo ist entschlossen sein
Versprechen zu halten aber wie soll er
in die belagerte Stadt hineinkommen und
wieder heraus
zu diesem Zeitpunkt fast unmöglich einen
Lieferwagen zu finden denn jeder wollte
so einen haben
der rote Lieferwagen war dann der
einzige den ich bekommen konnte
tausende fliehen aus Mario Paul
michaelo ist einer der wenigen die in
die Stadt zurückkehren
seinen Van hat er voll gepackt mit
Lebensmitteln und Medikamenten
am 8 März fährt er von Nico 300 km durch
besetztes Territorium nach Mario Paul
[Musik]
erreicht den ersten russischen
Kontrollpunkt 100 km vor der belagerten
Stadt
Barsche als erstes sah ich Militärgerät
und Soldaten als ich näher kam umringten
sie den väne und richteten ihre Waffen
auf mich
einer fing an den Wagen zu durchsuchen
überredet die Soldaten in passieren zu
lassen doch je näher er der Stadt kommt
desto unberechenbarer sind die Soldaten
an den Checkpoints
Leute ich habe nichts es ist alles weg
es war schwer die Checkpoints mit einem
Lächeln zu passieren wenn man an toten
vorbeifährt und weiß dass sie von diesen
Russen erschossen wird
beim letzten Kontrollpunkt verlässt
michailo sein Glück
golden sie fingen an den Wagen zu
plündern ich dachte sie nehmen alles mit
dann sagte der Kommandant wir lassen Sie
nicht durch drehen sie um fahren Sie
zurück
ignoriert den Befehl ihr kennt einen
anderen Weg in die Stadt
dann sah ich wie die Kanonen feuerten
eine nach der anderen
und mir wurde klar dass ich dahin fahre
wo diese Geschosse einschlagen
was zum Teufel mache ich denn
in den nächsten Wochen und Monaten wird
Mario Poll von der russischen Armee den
Erdboden gleichgemacht eine Strategie
der verbrannten Erde
doch statt den Widerstand zu brechen
steigt in der Ukraine die Zahl der
zivilen Helfer
freiwilligen Organisationen genießen
hier schon vor dem Krieg hohes Ansehen
jetzt helfen hunderttausende erledigen
humanitäre medizinische militärischer
oder logistischer Aufgaben
[Musik]
am Tag des russischen Angriffs steht bei
Sammler einem der größten
logistik-konzerne der Ukraine die
Arbeitsstelle
[Musik]
Geschäftsführer viktor-ko erinnert sich
in den ersten Stunden standen die
Telefone still alle waren damit
beschäftigt sich in Sicherheit zu
bringen um 9 Uhr morgens kam dann ein
Auftrag Medikamente von einem Ort in
Kiew zu einem anderen zu liefern eine
Entfernung von wenigen Kilometern aber
ich konnte niemanden erreichen bis
mittags gab es keine Logistik
Straßensperren blockieren den Weg in die
Hauptstadt vor den Tankstellen bilden
sich lange Schlangen der russische
Angriff droht das Land lahm zu legen
das alles zusammen die blockierten
Straßen die Raketenangriffe neue Routen
zu wenig Fahrzeuge zu wenig Fahrer zu
wenig Treibstoff
das war eine Herausforderung
gegründet mit kaum mehr als einer
Handvoll Mitarbeitern
inzwischen ist aus der Firma ein
international tätiges Unternehmen
geworden
Viktor lebt mit Frau und Kindern in Kiew
wir haben zwei Kinder einen 11-jährigen
Sohn und eine sechsjährige Tochter wir
leben in einem Vorort wir haben einen
Hund das ist unser Nest
Anfang 2022 steht die russische Invasion
kurz bevor
ich bezeichne mich als Patrioten zwei
Tage vor dem Angriff war ich im
einberufungsbüro und meldete mich
freiwillig
Victors Firma und seine persönliche
Erfahrung sind für die Verteidigung von
unschätzbarem Wert
ich war für die Logistik zuständig es
hatte keinen Sinn etwas anderes zu tun
die Logistik ist eine der
entscheidendsten Faktoren im Krieg
ohne Nachschub kommt jeder Angriff zum
Stillstand wie die russischen Truppen
bald feststellen
als die russischen Panzer in die Nähe
von Kiew vorrückten ging ihnen der
Treibstoff aus die Munition ging ihnen
aus und die Logistik konnte nicht
mithalten
hätten sie die richtige Logistik gehabt
wäre die Situation völlig anders gewesen
also keine Logistik kein Sieg
als ich die Kämpfe ausweiten wird der
Transport auch für das ukrainische
Militär zum größten logistischen Problem
es fehlt vor allem an geländetauglichen
Lastwagen
die aufgestellten Bataillone mussten mit
Waffen Lebensmitteln und Kleidung
versorgt werden aber es gab keine
Lastwagen
auch Ersatzteile und Munition fehlen an
der Front
sie sollen also drei waffenladungen an
verschiedene Orte bringen haben aber nur
zwei Trucks was macht man da
die Lösung des Problems liegt
überraschend nah
in Militärlagern der Ukraine stehen
tausende ausgemusterte Armeefahrzeuge
die alte sowjetische Fahrzeuge seit 30
Jahren stillgelegt
aber die Trucks sind in äußerst
schlechtem Zustand
[Musik]
haben Sie schon mal ein Auto gesehen das
verschrottet werden soll es gibt eine
Karosserie vier Räder einen Motor
vielleicht
wo andere Schrott sehen erkennt Viktor
eine Chance
unsere Idee da sind ein paar alte
Fahrzeuge reparieren wir sie einfach
für die Mechaniker eine echte
Herausforderung
wir brachten sieben Fahrzeuge zu tammler
wo wir eigene Werkstätten haben die
Fahrzeuge waren in unterschiedlichem
Zustand abgeschrieben sehr schlecht
extrem schlecht super schlecht
doch die ukrainische Armee braucht
tausende Lastwagen der Verschleiß im
Krieg ist gewaltig
und die versprochenen gepanzerten
Fahrzeuge aus dem Westen lassen anfangs
auf sich warten
der Bedarf steigt weiter als ukrainische
Einheiten im Nordosten des Landes
russische Truppen zurückdrängen auch
deren Angriff auf die Hauptstadt Kiew
ist gescheitert
[Musik]
unter den ersten Helfern die sich in die
gerade befreiten Gebiete im Großraum
kiew-wagen ist Tata Kepler sie hilft bei
der medizinischen Versorgung was sie
erlebt hat sie zutiefst verstört
[Musik]
wenn die Hölle existiert dann dort
wir werden nie wieder dieselben sein wie
vorher da kriegen
[Musik]
das Leben vor dem Krieg Erinnerungen wie
aus einer anderen Welt
[Musik]
Managerin einer der angesagtesten
Cocktailbars in Kiel sie hat gedichtet
und niedergeschrieben
[Musik]
es war ein aufregendes glückliches Leben
ich bin gereist habe gearbeitet Texte
geschrieben mich verliebt und Tango
getanzt
[Musik]
also
ich hatte eine kleine Jazzband ich habe
die Texte geschrieben und 2019 einen
Album veröffentlicht
[Musik]
mein ganzes Leben hatte mit Kreativität
zu tun
[Musik]
schon 2014 als Russland die Krim besetzt
und dem dombas gekämpft wird ist härter
als freiwillige im Einsatz
schon damals besorgt sie medizinische
Hilfsmittel
ganz am Anfang habe ich in den sozialen
Netzwerken aktiv Spenden gesammelt und
dann begann ich mich auf einzelne
Brigaden und Einheiten zu konzentrieren
die ich persönlich kannte und half ihnen
[Musik]
dann kommt der 24 Februar 2022
Uhr morgens rief mich mein Freund an und
sagte dass der Krieg begonnen habe und
von diesem Tag an bin ich nicht mehr zur
Arbeit gegangen
stattdessen arbeitet Tarte als
freiwillige Helferin und es sind nicht
nur Soldaten an der Front die
medizinische Hilfe brauchen
wir bekamen auch Anfragen von Zivilisten
die Apotheken waren geschlossen nichts
hatte geöffnet es gab keinen insulinmann
konnte es nirgends kaufen es war sehr
hart und schwierig
Tata beschafft Arzneimittel um sie in
den umliegenden Gemeinden zu verteilen
einer der ersten Orte den sie besucht
ist Butcher etwa 25 km nordwestlich von
Kiel
zu Beginn des Krieges waren russische
Truppen in den Vorort eingedrungen nach
heftigen Kämpfen hielten sie die Stadt
einem Monat lang besetzt dann gelingt es
ukrainischen Einheiten Botschaft
zurückzuerobern
Tata und ihr Team sind die ersten
medizinischen Helfer die ankommen
diese Fahrt werde ich nie vergessen so
hatte ich noch nie gebetet
[Musik]
wer bei mir da ich erinnere mich dass
wir mit dem Auto unterwegs waren und da
lag ein alter Mann am Straßenrand er war
auf dem Weg Irgendwohin gewesen er wurde
durch einen Schuss in die Schläfe
getötet
Bonbon Papierchen russische
bonbon-papierchen
[Musik]
die zerstörte Stadt wird zum Sinnbild
russischer Kriegsverbrechen
schockierende Bilder gehen um die Welt
von hunderten Toten Zivilisten darunter
mindestens 9 Kinder
wenn man dahin kommt tut es körperlich
weh es tut weh zu atmen das tut weh es
anzuschauen für Menschen die nicht dort
waren ist es sehr schwer den Horror zu
begreifen den wir empfanden
[Musik]
wie Tata setzen sich viele Ukrainerinnen
und Ukrainer freiwillig ein auch direkt
an der Front
die Armee der Ukraine vergrößert sich
mit den freiwilligen auf schätzungsweise
500.000 Personen
in der Nationalgarde den Grenztruppen
oder der Territorialverteidigung
gleichzeitig kontrolliert Russland
weiter große Gebiete im Osten und der
Ring um mariopol schließt sich immer
enger
Chef will nach mariopoly hinein um seine
Mitarbeiter zu retten
er fährt durch Artillerie Feuer und über
vermiete Straßen
michaelo erkennt seine Heimatstadt kaum
wieder wenige Tage sind vergangen doch
nun liegen ganze Häuserblocks im Schutt
und Asche
ich habe sehr betrunkene Menschen
gesehen weil es nichts zu Essen gab und
in den Supermärkten nur noch Alkohol zu
finden war
als michaelo seinen Nachtclub erreicht
wartet seine Belegschaft bereits auf ihn
wohl besser
Ratten raus das heißt Buchhalterin Jenny
als Barkeeper sie sagten micha ist da
micha ist angekommen
aber sie sind nicht die einzigen die auf
Hilfe hoffen
der Club war dunkel es gab kein Licht
und kein Wasser ich sah viele Kinder
Onkel micha ist gekommen sie hat den
ganzen Tag gewartet hallo du bist
viele Leute die ich nicht kenne hatten
sich in dem Club versammelt der kein
Club mehr war sondern ein
Luftschutzkeller
doch dann verschlechtert sich die Lage
der russische Beschuss wird immer
heftiger ein Fluchtversuch zu gefährlich
statt die anderen zu retten sitzt
Michael nun mit ihnen in der Falle
unter dauerndem Beschuss nutzt der
stattdessen seinen vanum Hilfsgüter an
verschiedene Orte zu liefern
warte bleibt zurück
nein auf dieser Seite
das sind deine Medikamente
6 Tage später beschließt mich Hailo
einen Fluchtversuch zu wagen sein
Nachtclub ist inzwischen Zufluchtsort
für mehr als 200 Menschen geworden
doch wen soll er mitnehmen
[Musik]
wir sind den Menschen und den Kindern so
nahe gekommen dass man sie nicht im
Stich lassen kann es ist als würdest du
einen Teil deiner Familie aufgeben
[Musik]
michailo entscheidet Mütter und Kinder
zuerst ich habe meine Angestellten Jungs
und Mädels gebeten zu warten damit ich
die Leute mit Kindern mitnehmen konnte
ich habe selbst vier Kinder ich bin
Vater ich weiß wie schwierig es ist für
die Menschen für die Eltern
[Musik]
am Tag der Abreise packt michailo den
roten Lieferwagen an der Straße direkt
vor seinem Club
jawohl ich ging nach draußen und dann
hörte ich das Geräusch von Flugzeugen
ich hörte wie die Flugzeuge näher näher
kam
runter
[Musik]
Explosionen aber die erste Explosion man
hörte die später
ich erinnere mich an die Druckquelle sie
war warm
[Musik]
zwei Bomben sind direkt neben dem
Nachtclub eingeschlagen
es gibt verletzte und tote
michaelos schnelle Reaktion und der alte
van haben noch Schlimmeres verhindert
gut gemacht mein Schatz
der Lieferwagen hat viele Bombensplitter
abgefangen eine riesige Menge ich habe
diesen Wagen gepriesen
aber ohne funktionsfähigen Wagen ist die
Rettungsmission endgültig gescheitert
[Musik]
ich dachte dass er nicht anspringen
würde die Windschutzscheibe und die
Seitentür waren herausgerissen
Beulen ein Haufen Splitter im Motor aber
selbst in diesem Zustand musste ich
einfach den Zündschlüssel drehen
am 14 märz beginnt die Evakuierung
ich weiß nicht wie viel es waren ich
habe nicht gezählt ich weiß es nicht so
viele wie hineinpassten manche standen
manche saßen sie
die Evakuierung gelingt doch michailo
will auch die anderen retten
er will noch einmal in das immer stärker
abgeriegelte mariopol fahren
als ich das zweite Mal zurück kam war es
noch emotionaler denn alle haben darauf
gewartet dass ich zurückkomme und sie
mitnehmen
bis Ende April unternimmt michaelhof 5
Fahrten
[Musik]
bemerkt nicht mehr dass die Granaten
fliegen und das brennt man beachte das
nicht mehr man weiß nur dass man
ankommen muss
am 2 Mai will er ein sechstes Mal nach
Mario Poll fahren
die Russen beschießen weiterhin das
stahlwerksthal gestern gab es 35 Luft
hunderte verletzte Soldaten und
Zivilisten darunter auch Kinder sollen
laut ukrainischen Angaben noch in
Schutzräumen des Stahlwerks ausmachen
[Musik]
wir spielen mit unseren Handys aber wir
wollen nach Hause um die Sonne zu sehen
Video mit den Kindern von Style gesehen
habe habe ich mich entschlossen dorthin
zu fahren
sobald ich das jemandem erzählte ist es
du bist verrückt du wirst es nicht
schaffen
eine Evakuierung ist nur mit russischer
Zustimmung möglich
als Teil eines humanitären Konvois dann
kam ein Checkpoint und ich sagte den
anderen sie sollten sich unter keinen
Umständen nähern
am Kontrollpunkt wird mich Heilo sofort
verhaftet und in ein Internierungslager
gebracht
der evakuierungshelfer ist nun den
russischen Soldaten ausgeliefert
[Musik]
viele ukraineerinnen und Ukraine haben
Dinge erlebt die ihr Leben für immer
verändert haben
Leid Ungewissheit Trauer und Verlust
können tiefe seelische Wunden
hinterlassen
Dimitri schuhdorf erlebt die ersten
Kriegstage als Schock der Musiker ist
wie gelähmt
ich konnte nicht spielen ich konnte
nicht singen ich machte ein Lied an fing
an zu heulen hielt das Auto an und stieg
aus für mich war in diesem Moment alles
vollkommen tot
[Musik]
Dimitri ist in der Ukraine ein populärer
Musiker bekannt unter dem Projektnamen
Piano boy
mit seiner Band hat er in der gesamten
Ukraine und auf der ganzen Welt gespielt
[Musik]
ich bin mein ganzes Leben lang Musiker
gewesen als ich mit vier Jahren zum
ersten Mal ein Klavier sah zog es mich
in seinen Bann und mein Schicksal war
besiegelt in den letzten 10 oder 12
Jahren habe ich mein eigenes Projekt
namens Piano Boy wirklich wir spielen
Musik die irgendwo zwischen Rock n' Roll
und Klassiker
[Musik]
während der ersten sechs Kriegswochen
fühlt sich Dimitri ziemlich
niedergeschlagen dann kontaktiert ihn
ein Freund der organisiert
Veranstaltungen für traumatisierte
Soldaten die können Dimitris Hilfe
brauchen insgesamt er fragte ob ich für
das Militär spielen wollte ich sagte
wovon redest du welche Konzerte wie
kannst du nur daran denken ich bin in so
einem Loch dass ich mich nicht
herausziehen kann
nach einer Woche Grübeln bricht Dimitri
mit seinen Musikerkollegen auf um wieder
aufzutreten
ich darf nicht sagen
handelte die eine sehr wichtige
militärische Einrichtung beachten dort
haben wir ein Konzert gegeben
[Musik]
ja
ich habe die Hälfte des Konzerts geheult
ich weiß nicht wie das die Soldaten
aufgehalten haben soll stattdessen haben
sie mich aufgehalten
schon nach den ersten Auftritten ändert
sich die Stimmung der Konzerte
[Musik]
irgendwann hatte ich das Gefühl dass es
auch für die Soldaten eine emotionale
Verbindung war
immer wieder spielt Dimitri auch in
nächster Nähe zur Front
manchmal geht es zu wie in
spionagefilmen wir steigen in ein Auto
ein dann wechseln wir das Auto
die Gefahr für sein Leben nimmt der
Musiker im Kopf
es gab Situationen in denen eine Rakete
direkt über meinen Kopf flog aber wenn
man für Soldaten spielt denkt man
darüber nicht nach denn da wo sie
herkommen haben Sie sicher schlimmeres
erlebt
hier
[Musik]
sagt er habe seine Rolle im Krieg
gefunden Musik als Therapie für ihn und
die Soldaten gleichermaßen
[Musik]
manchmal fängt man ganz leicht an auf
eine fast heilsame Weise sehr sehr zart
um mit Ihnen zu kommunizieren und dann
schaut man welche Wirkung das hat
Jungs von der Luftverteidigung sagten
mir mal sie würden mehr russische
Raketen abschießen weil sie dieses
Konzert in sich trügen
in einem Krankenhaus in Odessa wird
Dimitri von einem Geiger in Uniform
begleitet
gesagt er sagte ich habe immer davon
geträumt mit dir zu spielen ich sagte
lass uns spielen
[Musik]
Moment
für Dimitri auch ein Sinnbild dieses
Krieges
wo ist da ist ein Geigenspieler der
kürzlich noch in Clubs gespielt hat und
jetzt ist er Sanität
[Musik]
wir sind wir wir sind Leute die bereit
sind sich zu opfern damit die Wahrheit
siegt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
tatsächlich werden die meisten Ukrainer
unfreiwillig Opfer des Krieges
in dem heftig umkämpften Dörfern und
Städten fehlt es den Bewohnern auf dem
Nötigsten an Lebensmitteln sauberem
Wasser Strom Medikamenten
in Botschaft werden die Helfer um Tata
Kepler mit dem russischen Massaker an
der Zivilbevölkerung konfrontiert
trotzdem macht das Team weiter sie
helfen Verletzten und leisten
medizinische Grundversorgung
waren wir mit einem medizinischen
Rucksack unterwegs
etwas gegen den Blutdruck für Sie und
für ihren Mann
sie müssen zu einem Kardiologen
dann wurden daraus Autos voller
Medikamente
schwere Nekrose ein alter Mann sie haben
es mit Honig behandelt stell dir das mal
vor
dass du da bist
mit besserer Ausrüstung Reisen Tata und
ihr Team in entlegene Gebiete wo es
weder Krankenhäuser noch Ärzte gibt
wir können Wunden verbinden Epilepsie
und Asthma Medikamente verabreichen wir
haben Insulin und verschiedene ähnliche
Dinge dabei
ich verteile Amarillo
[Musik]
wir helfen auch bei glücklichen
Ereignissen
der Moment der Wahrheit
hauptsache es ist am Leben gesund und
glücklich
[Musik]
ich werde nicht aufhören bis wir
gewonnen haben ich werde alles tun um
den Sieg näher zu bringen
[Musik]
ich glaube je mehr Arbeit wie hier
leisten desto schneller werden wir
siegen
[Musik]
seit Beginn des russischen
angriffskriegs sind laut offiziellen
Angaben mindestens 8000 Zivilisten und
mehr als 16.000 ukrainische Soldaten
getötet worden
ich habe Angst
[Musik]
Katharina rotarenko gehört zu einer
Gruppe von Freiwilligen die nach
Überresten von gefallenen Soldaten
suchen
die bergungshelfer sorgen dafür dass die
Soldaten ein würdiges Begräbnis erhalten
eine Arbeit die körperlich und psychisch
belastet
wir dürfen nicht zulassen dass Menschen
in diesem Krieg vermisst bleiben
wir müssen alle zurückbringen die ihr
Leben für unsere Unabhängigkeit für
unseren Staat für uns alle gegeben haben
das ist sehr sehr wichtig
vor dem Krieg ist Katharina auf der
Suche nach dem richtigen Beruf das
einzige was sie nicht machen will ist
beim Militär zu dienen
ich habe eine wunderbare Familie mein
Vater war bei den Streitkräften meine
Mutter war grenzschutzbeamtin und als
Teenager sagte ich ich werde nie zum
Militär gehen als der Krieg ausbricht
meldet sie sich doch als freiwillige bei
Militär
was soll ich denn zu Hause machen
einfach nur rumsitzen das kommt nicht in
frage ich würde verrückt werden ich habe
keine Kinder ich habe keinen Mann ich
bleibe und werde helfen
katharina ist damaliger Chef leitet auch
ein Zentrum das nach vermissten Soldaten
aus dem Zweiten Weltkrieg sucht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
dann wird die Gruppe vom ukrainischen
Militär gebeten gefallene Soldaten
dieses Krieges zu bergen
bis zu meinem ersten Einsatz hatte ich
noch nie eine Leiche gesehen ich fragte
mich ob ich damit klar kommen würde
beim dritten oder vierten Einsatz kamen
wir an einen ziemlich heiklen Ort es gab
viele Leichen
es war eine anstrengende und harte
Arbeit aber ich habe es überstanden
gegenwärtig sucht Katharinas Einheit in
der Region Nikolai
Monate lang besetzt von russischen
Truppen dann von der ukrainischen Armee
zurückerobert
die Industriestadt steht noch immer
unter russischem Beschuss
anhand von militärischen Daten suchen
die bergungshelfer gezielt nach Feldern
in denen Kämpfe stattgefunden haben
Drohnen helfen bei der ersten Erkundung
[Musik]
sieht nicht alt aus
dann überprüft ein Sprengstoffexperte
den Boden
es gibt viele Blindgänger viele aktive
Minen
und an nichts denken man hat die Gefahr
immer im Kopf
sie durchsuchen auch verlassene schützen
hier könnten Soldaten monatelang gelebt
haben
es ist ziemlich groß man kann einen
Tisch sehen vielleicht war es ihre Küche
das ein Schlafsack
[Musik]
ein Abzeichen ich werde ein Foto davon
machen
man darf bei dieser Arbeit nicht
emotional werden wenn man alles an sich
heran lässt
kann man es mental nicht bewältigen
in diesem Schützengraben ist nichts zu
finden außer den Überresten eines
soldatenalltags
nichts
[Applaus]
wird eine Leiche gefunden werden die
Fundumstände notiert anschließend wird
der Tote zur Identifizierung ins
Leichenschauhaus gebracht die
Angehörigen können dann Abschied nehmen
solange ein Mensch als vermisst gilt
hoffen Angehörige dass er zurückkehrt
dieses Warten endet nie
darum ist unsere Arbeit so wichtig
damit alle nach Hause zurückkehren
können
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jedes zurück eroberte ukrainische Gebiet
ist ein potenzieller Einsatzort für
Katharina und ihre Kollegen
[Musik]
je weiter die ukrainische Armee vorrückt
desto wichtiger wird auch die Versorgung
der Soldaten an der Front
der Versuch von viktorschewtschenko alte
sowjetische Lastwagen zum Laufen zu
bringen erweist sich als große
Herausforderung
wir können das nicht reparieren der
Druck ist zu hoch können wir die
Drehbank benutzen wir können was drehen
dann Schweißen die Dichtung müssen wir
aber irgendwie einpressen schau es ist
Metall
die Mechaniker finden einen Weg
Ende August hatten wir sieben neue
Fahrzeuge lackiert und alles
bleibt nur noch die Abnahme durch das
Militär
wir zeigten die Trucks dem Kommandeur
der Territorialverteidigung und der
meinte sagt mir was ihr braucht und ich
helfe euch ist zu besorgen einer
scherzte geholt der Fahrzeuge von den
Toten zurück
bis Ende des Jahres sind 130 Lastwagen
repariert alle werden sofort an der
Front eingesetzt
wenn man null Lastwagen hat und nach
vier Monaten 1030 ist das auf jeden Fall
ein Plus
aber wie bei den Ameisen erfüllt jeder
seine kleine Rolle und dann wird daraus
ein großes Ding
eine halbe Million Euro hat das Projekt
bisher gekostet ein Bruchteil dessen was
neue Fahrzeuge gekostet hätten
meine Firma hat die ersten Fahrzeuge
finanziert auch jetzt noch unterstützen
wir das Projekt und ich habe einige
meiner Kollegen mit ins Boot geholt
[Musik]
die Logistikbranche hat sich schnell auf
die neuen Zeiten eingestellt
waren wir wieder bei bis zu 95% unserer
üblichen Auslastung
und nach dem Sieg das ist allen klar
werden wir das Land neu aufbauen müssen
[Musik]
in der Nähe von mariopol sitzt Michael
opodi Chef zwei Tage lang in einem
russischen Gefängnis weil er versucht
hat Kinder aus asofsteil zu retten
sie begannen mit Verhören dann
Elektroschocks es Handlung
am ersten Tag packte einer von ihnen
eine Pistole aus und drückte sie mir in
die Hand
ich hatte wirklich Angst dass sie mich
rausbringen und erschießen
hat Glück im Unglück
Telefon
es waren viele Videos von den Kindern
und den Leuten
die Handy-Videos belegen dass er ein
einfacher ziviler Helfer ist
sie schauten es sich an und sagten in
Ordnung wir glauben ihn
am 6 mai startet die Evakuierung der
letzten Zivilisten aus dem stallwerk
russland hat eine Feuerpause zugestimmt
auch michailo wird überraschend
freigelassen
es waren noch 30 andere Freiwillige in
gefangen aber nur mich haben sie frei
gelassen
am 20 mai endet der Kampf um Mario Poll
die letzten Verteidiger im Stahlwerk
legen die Waffen nieder und ergeben sich
nach seiner Freilassung arbeitet
michailo weiter als Freiwilliger und
bringt Hilfsgüter in zerstörte Städte
heute baut er Versorgungszentren auf die
Menschen Strom und Wasser bringen
beides fehlt in besonders stark
umkämpften Orten
[Musik]
März 2023 michailo feiert seinen 37
geburtstag
[Musik]
[Applaus]
für meine Kinder
[Musik]
auch nach über einem Jahr ist der
Ausgang des Krieges ungewiss
ich denke nicht einmal darüber nach wir
wollen nur den Sieg sonst nichts
fünf freiwillige
stellvertretend für Hunderttausende
Musiker Musik ist eine Möglichkeit sich
lebendig zu fühlen das ist meine Waffe
das ist meine Stellung die ich nicht
aufgeben darf
dann ein überraschendes treffen
Achtung wer sind sie wir sind sie
hierher gekommen ich habe mich verlaufen
werde
alle Ukrainer sind jetzt freiwillige
Menschen
majestätisch unglaublich
sehen Sie wir kämpfen für unsere
Freiheit
entweder Freiheit oder nichts
in der nächsten Folge ein gespaltenes
Land warum viele Russinnen und Russen
die Invasion der Ukraine unterstützen
und manche ihre Freiheit riskieren weil
sie den Krieg beenden wollen
Tatort Ukraine Menschen im Krieg
[Musik]